on ne changera pas malgré les millions
c'est ce qu'ont indiqué à l'unisson les
huit membres de la famille monsieur
julien qui se séparent le plus gros
montant offert au lotto max une famille
tissée serrée qui gardera les pieds sur
terre selon qu'un gorille mathieu qui a
validé le billet gagnant au lendemain du
tirage je suis quelqu'un il est très
terre à terre et je sais que l'argent
n'importe quel bonheur l'agent peut pas
acheter le bonheur la famille par
exemple salle apporte le bonheur
reste que la famille de la région de
québec n'y crois toujours pas lorsque
grégory appelé sa mère pour lui annoncer
la nouvelle
celle ci lui a demandé des confirmations
j'ai dit là grégory ton père et moi on
n'a pas vraiment les moyens de manquer
de l' ouvrage pour niaiseries ou pour
une mauvaise blague prêtent moins
quelqu'un qui est avec toi pour me
confirmer que tu me dis la vérité
un gros lot de 70 millions qui a une
signification particulière pour la
famille une histoire se cache derrière
lui billets la marraine de grigory s'est
enlevé la vie il y a dix ans son fiel
acheter le billet gagnant le 25 février
jour de son anniversaire avec le disque
sommes complémentaires
c'était la marraine de grégory et elle
disait toujours grégory c'est l'homme de
ma vie parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas
avoir d'enfant pierre épaisseur ajoutons
à cela que la mère de 3d gagnante avait
prédit un billet gagnant et l htc c'est
bien religieusement et sur son lit de
mort a nous a dit les faits je vais
trouver un moyen de revenir vous font le
trou est elle le trouvait une histoire
de famille qui n'a pas manqué de toucher
yves corbeil qui remet pourtant des
chèques aux gagnants depuis une
quarantaine d'années c'est vrai c'est
déjà mon jeu tellement simple tellement
le fun tergal puis ils t'envoient de la
moe dans les yeux c'est moi je trouve ça
moi je vous trouve très beau et très
belle tout le monde
si félix morissette boulud radio canada
québec